um i do have a question though because i
kind of remembered this uh in the
experience i had in the past week do you
guys get have you guys ever gotten fever
dreams
um would you buy a fever dream can you
find one for me
you have when you have a fever when you
have a really bad fever and you start
dreaming really weird [ __ ] because i
thought it was just a saying i thought
it was just a term and phrase right
until i started dating sydney who gets
like
such some of like the most [ __ ]
weirdest fever dreams i've ever heard in
my life while conscious huh like all
like while i'll sleep
i'm like like okay okay so what are you
gonna walk oh it's just [ __ ] ravens
like she's running around the apartment
or she asleep wakes up and then it's
like gone you don't believe this dream i
had i was president i don't think that's
a favorite dream i think that's just
like going psycho
can we get a
definition of where
comes from okay so so when you have like
when you have a really bad fever
obviously you try to rest you your body
tries to rest right at least some
people's body tries to rest um and uh
and then you go to sleep and you're like
sweating you start having a really bad
fever you know as your body tries to
fight off this illness and then some
people or i'm saying some people because
the experience i've seen it happened to
is with sydney and she'll just wake up
drenched full of sweat and was just like
honey i just saw connor in a bikini
running on the beach what the [ __ ] is
going on where am i right now like it's
it's she was saying she'll just wake up
and just say like the weirdest [ __ ]
[ __ ] that happened and i'm like like i'm
like what what what just happened she
was like oh it was just a few and that's
that's believable actually that is
possible
that wasn't a fever drink that was just
an episode of cosplay yeah because like
i've never had like a single fever dream
at all or like i actually i really ever
dreamed the the problem is no no it's
it's never gonna dream because i think
i'm the exact same way whereas like i
don't remember 99 of my dreams
and it's [ __ ] up because it's like i i
remember i remember some mornings i wake
up and i'm like i remember having a
really good dream and then as i am
waking up and i'm trying to remember the
dream again i'm like yeah and it's wait
what the [ __ ] did i just dream about
and it's so weird because it it
literally like fades away right as i'm
trying to think about it
but all i remember is that
i had a good dream yeah but if he told
me to recite it i'd be like i don't know
i don't remember i like cause to me i
think i feel like i've just rarely ever
dreamed i i don't know because like if i
have a dream oh you do dream everyone
dreams i'm sure i do i'm sure i'm sure
i'm sure i do you're not a [ __ ]
reptile like you do dream
or unpleasant dream sleepers can
experience when they have a fever
i'm sure i've had a fever drinking so
sure yeah but they happen similar to
other dreams that can happen during any
stage of sleep mostly
yeah it just seems like her dreams when
she has a fever is just like the wildest
ones you know it's so strange i don't
remember my dreams
ver i very rarely remember them yeah
maybe like once every month yeah i don't
remember really yeah i i probably can
only remember like two nightmares but
but but like if i have a dream i like i
remember the fact that i had a dream but
like most but most nights i wake up and
i'm just like i there was there was just
a void in my head there was nothing
there was nothing i dreamt nothing can
you can you feel the sense of time
passing when you're aware that you're
dreaming
yeah have you ever have you ever had a
lucid dream no i really want to though
those are the funnest ones i've only had
once i've only had it a few times i
think i've had situations where what i
wanted to happen in the dream during it
did happen but i feel like it's a battle
i don't know this is so hard to remember
this stuff this is what scientists have
been trying to like [ __ ] figure out
for like hundreds of years yeah i don't
know
have you ever had a dream that's like
been so vivid
that it's kind of like just stuck with
you for like years and you can still
recite it because i don't remember like
most of my dreams
i have one nightmare i had when i was
little that i think is the reason why
i'm afraid of heights now right uh so
like you know how they say like you
can't die in your dream right yeah
because you've never experienced it
before i think that's bs well actually i
thought it was bs2 until i had tried i
pretty sure i'd die in a lot of my
dreams
[Music]
all right i don't know no no no no no
food voicing
i've i've i've done one of those food
points
i've definitely died in my dreams but
i've just woken up immediately as i've
done yeah yeah yeah really do you always
wake up is that like guaranteed i feel
like i've reset it i don't [ __ ] know
what it is
you just remember
you died for real
you responding your dreams i'm pretty
sure i've respawned in my dream i'm near
certain i've respawned in my dream the
the only nightmare i've had that i can
still vividly remember is i it was a
really short dream but i was like flying
in my room
and then for some reason i just stopped
and then i okay and then just i just
picked a young joey flying i'm just like
flying my room like
like that yeah uh and then i just
stopped i remember i stopped and our
house was like uh it was like two
stories and we had like the spiral
staircase that went down to like the
basement floor yeah and i remember i
just stopped and i looked down at the
spiral staircase and i just dropped
like head first
and i vividly remember
my face got about this close to the
ground and then
right and just [ __ ] myself right and
i think from that point on i got afraid
of heights
because i vividly remember the feeling
of falling and it was horrible
your brain made a traumatic experience
for you yeah that's so strange like like
to me like the one traumatic dream that
i've had that has stuck with me for
years
was i remember i remember this one time
um i was living this dream right
and i would wake up in my bed in my room
that i was living at at the time and i
would just go about my day right and
then
and then it would just be a normal day
and then something would happen that
would just be like out the ordinary like
i would see
i would see like
i would see like a twin
followed by another twin like i just
noticed a glitch in the matrix or
something and then as soon as i saw that
it would like the dream reset and i'd
wake up again i would and i would think
that i was in the real world and i would
go about my day and then i would notice
another glitch in the in reality it was
it's it's [ __ ] nightmare fuel because
like i literally i literally repeat this
cycle and every time i would get more
and more paranoid that i didn't know if
i was in the dream world or if i was
actually awake i was like i was like is
this a dream of because like i would go
about my day and
and i remember the exact moment i woke
up was about the tenth time when i like
i like went through an entire day
thinking okay i'm awake i'm awake and i
remember going to the toilet
and i was uh i was um getting ready for
bed and i looked at the mirror and then
my reflection turned like
turned away
i didn't believe the fact that i was
actually awake right it it
it literally [ __ ] with my mind for
like an entire few days because i i i
went about those few days being like
where's the glitch where's when's it
gonna happen when's it gonna come out
we're not twins yeah yeah
that's [ __ ] up that literally like
that's scary i don't know how my mind
created such a [ __ ] up situation that
it literally like [ __ ] up my mind in
real life maybe maybe i'm still in the
dream maybe maybe i'm just trash tasting
you mentioned that you like flying right
yeah when i'm in dreams and i like let's
say i do something that i know is is
impossible are you aware that you're
like you know it's impossible that
you're dreaming because i often always
get i'm aware that it's impossible but i
just
i think because like lucid dreaming is
where it's like you're aware that you're
what you're doing
so you take full advantage of that i
think lucid dreaming was where you then
controlled said dream yeah yeah yeah i
can't control cedric to me i know i'm in
a dream a lot of the time okay so okay
so i can't control my dream when i'm in
when i'm in lucid dreaming state but
it's more of like
it's it's more of like it's more like
you've realized that you're in gta with
cheats on
you know that's that's how i imagine it
right because there have been times
where i'm just like oh [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
dreaming all right let me let am i
dreaming let me try flying okay oh i'm
flying now yeah brilliant a [ __ ]
dream this is amazing that sounds like
you have cheat songs yeah i can't when i
because i don't have dreams often but
when i do yeah at some point in the
dream i figure out this is a dream
right like something will happen that
my brain chose to to make happen but i
also am aware that that is not possible
and that i'm now aware that i'm in a
dream but it doesn't change how i behave
like i know that i'm in a dream but i
still go on the dream this is so strange
what's wrong with our brains [ __ ]
weird like i had this dream recently i
can't remember the fall of it i told i
told the dream on stream it was
something like um i i i was in a
situation where
i'd been falsely accused of stealing
this game cartridge yeah and then i was
then arrested for it and i was like no
i'm not getting arrested for this i
didn't i didn't steal it i refuse and so
then i then i like killed one of the
cops and like ran away because he was
trying to arrest me over the [ __ ]
and then it turned out into this like
massive shootout and stuff now then i
somehow kept uh getting away and then
eventually i got caught and then i went
to prison and then i understood i was in
a dream at this point so then somehow i
magically then got a phone this is like
an izakaya i had this phone in prison
that i was then using to then play games
and stuff and like have a normal life in
prison yeah and i don't know why then my
charger broke and
i remember this happened and i was like
[ __ ] well my charges broke and then i
just skipped and i had a charger and i
was like great
i just skipped i just skipped the point
where my brain had to like think hard
enough to come up with a reason why i
needed the charger
i don't understand why this happens
though but did you realize it was a
dream or yeah about halfway through the
dream i understood it was a dream yeah
but i did but you didn't you don't take
advantage of it you just i don't know
how to
like because i was about to say i love
how in the dream you still got arrested
he's taking an ill in the dream
it was my dream i didn't i wouldn't get
a [ __ ] day like you wouldn't go to
brazil
right and then and then i i remember no
no
this is incorrect actually i didn't get
the charger i got really this is where i
reset so i went to the roof of the
prison because i couldn't i couldn't get
a charger so i thought what's the
[ __ ] point if i can't play games yeah
and i jumped off the roof of the prison
and then i reset in the prison
[Laughter]
died i died and then i just in my head i
remember there was a jump
i i remember i died and then i just
appeared back in the prison again with
the charged iphone with a new charger
it's like the worst version of edge of
tomorrow
i just don't know why this was happening
why i understood it was a dream why
can't i have some control over it
they're all [ __ ] dreams i always have
[ __ ] dreams
but at least you remember like
at least because to me like a lot of
night like say for example like last
night right to me it's like okay i'm
falling asleep falling asleep falling
asleep one second later oh it's 7 a.m
yeah like there's i i feel no perception
of time no okay when you wake up can you
feel
the time without looking at the clock
yeah sometimes
yes but not accurately i feel like i'm
pretty [ __ ] good at it now i don't
know
if i'm getting older it depends on how
good my sleep cycle is at that time um
sometimes like now it's a bit [ __ ] up
because uh kovid just made me want to
sleep all the time so i'm just like okay
now now i can't tell because my body's
constantly tired but before then i would
be like you know you know sometimes you
wake up and you're like it's gonna be 15
minutes before the alarm goes yeah i
mean you look at the time every time you
look at the time you're like
i'm i'm a [ __ ] genius
the reason why i asked do you know that
is because i was like in like if i asked
you your dreams right do you do you know
that there was a flow of time in your
dreams
see this is weird i know how much time
is passing in the dream in the real
world isn't this weird
how strange is that that's that's
against inception rules though because
like
we all
we all know we all know time passes slow
in the dream world so because i'll wake
up right after a dream or whatever and
you know it'd be like 5 00 a.m and then
i'd be like i like that dream i'm also
gonna go back to bed yeah and then i
know
when i'm in the dream how much time is
passing because when i wake up the exact
amount of time that i thought had passed
in the dream had passed in real life is
this so strange i think that's just your
subconscious might be like like counting
the time maybe yeah it's almost like an
alternate reality do you have a level
like you need to [ __ ] [ __ ] the match
yeah
do you ever like have a really fun dream
and then you get actively pissed off
when you like wake up
oh my god i remember this i remember
some of like the funnest lucid dreams
i've had and then [ __ ] sydney wakes
up i was like god god let's cuddle and
i'm just like [ __ ] off sydney i'm flying
right now i'm flying sydney i was on
episode 24 and i was the botanist
i was supposed to get what i deserved
the worst the worst one for me is like
when i'm having a good dream because i
don't remember most of my good dreams
right yeah but it's like i remember i
wake up and i'm just like
man i don't remember what i just dreamed
but
maybe if i go back to
sleep again
and so i go back to sleep and i don't
dream again i was like no
it's gone forever like like to me to me
that there's a point right because to me
i've i've had it before where i've had
like really really fun dreams and i like
you half wake up but before your mind
fully wakes up you're like go back to
sleep and then
sometimes i've been able like to like
reinsert myself into the matrix right
god i'm getting in there i'm going in
i'm going
so i know sometimes like i wake up i'm
like if i go to if i go to sleep now if
i go to sleep right now i can go i can
jack back in and then like
i get so sad when i like try to [ __ ]
will myself to sleep because you you
know when you try to will yourself to
sleep most of the time it doesn't
[ __ ] work right but sometimes like i
i just like try to like will myself to
sleep and five minute passes i'm just
like
ah i'm awake now [ __ ] my life this is
the this is the real world i think i
used to do that but i don't ever try
that anymore i think sometimes i'm like
yeah whatever just get on with it i'll
just
do you have a theme to most your dreams
or your dreams because they say that
your dreams are normally like
reoccurring-ish sort of like they're
similar
no events ah no not really for me
i just die in a lot of my dreams
i don't know what that says about me
yeah uh maybe some dream expert but even
that you know how people are like
dreamologists yeah the dreams uh they
they your dream if whatever you do in
the dream there's a there's a real
meaning to it in real life
maybe i don't know like if you're
stressed out then you're dreaming about
your teeth falling out and stuff like
that something like that right where
they think that every single thing that
you can dream of has a real life
counterpart emotion that you're feeling
right i think there is to some extent
but yeah i'm like
yeah i get like really high
high concept dreams sometimes um like i
get like like i i told you like the the
the dream i just had but like sometimes
i just dream
and then i wake up and i'm just like
that's a really cool [ __ ] film idea
that's a really cool film
basically right you know it's uh i don't
know some
it's so weird something i i like i don't
know how my mind works because sometimes
i'm just like
damn i dreamed that that was such a cool
[ __ ] idea what the [ __ ]
how the [ __ ] did my mind come up with
that concept what language do you dream
in as as as because all three of us can
speak two languages right yeah like what
what language do you usually draw
english uh english for me is that i've
rarely like dreamed in time unless i've
unless it's when i'm like living in
thailand and i'm like using it more um
more often that's so weird like i
remember like 90 of my dreams are in
japanese
okay i don't know why what language do
you think in though
depends that's that's probably why
that's probably why right because like i
i
i don't normally think in thai but
there's been points where i've lived in
thailand and then my thoughts start
getting like jumbled up and i start
start thinking in a different language
as well which is like it's it's really
like how do you describe thinking in a
different language as someone who only
speaks one language it's
i don't i don't know how to like
properly describe it thinking about how
you think is also weird
now i'm like i'm like i don't talk to
myself and i think i don't think so but
maybe i do talk to myself and i think
i'm not sure some people can't though
right
some people like physically can't think
out no no now that you're telling me
that i'm talking to myself while i'm
thinking now i'm doing it but i'm pretty
sure i don't do it i think i should do
things
i don't i just don't think i just think
i'd talk to myself in my head yeah out
loud if i talk yeah because i remember i
remember reading about you know deaf
people thinking in sign language and
that just like that blows my [ __ ]
mind you know it just i can't even like
come close to conceptualizing it you
know but i know i know it happens i know
people do it but like you know it's it's
it's so weird it's so weird to me